all those well-behaved disney princesses  are crying out for a dark witch makeover  right with their pastel puffy gowns  perfect hair and subtle makeup  disney princesses aren't exactly cutting  edge with their beauty and fashion  but the artist behind the ekg arts  tiktok account has brought our favorite  ladies  over to the dark side watch as the royal  squad gets  wicked glow-ups  [Music]  do  [Music]  so  [Music]  uh  [Music]  uh  [Music]  then  [Music]  uh  [Music]  uh  [Music]  my  [Music]  my  [Music]  we've got one burning question we need  you to answer you buttes  which disney princess dark witch blow up  do you think is the most wicked wade in  with your thoughts in the comments  section below and hit that like button  to show your love for your favorite  royal squad  thanks for watching  [Music]